I'm trying to move it off to seven
minutes now and seven minutes batters
yes
[Music]
[Music]
potentially there was a taxi sent let's
just just hit them up and say Gary's
just looking to get together with you
yeah we're just trying to jam together
thanks weak yep still important right
yeah dude yeah he's trying to get that
before to come through on city well
that's [ __ ] nuts
yes yes it's they can fly me in really
really really efficiently yeah I would
consider leaving cancer like six hours
yeah what up team Gary V followers
number one I see some of you following
team Gary more than me
it hurts my [ __ ] feelings you might
just be all like more than he's ok with
that
and he talked about it understood you
were gonna do drinks for an hour so we
move either or the hour with yeah time
another thousand
Thank You Amitabha scheduling point yeah
yeah if that one's the next week are you
looking for you Alex you're you Alex
Alex are I'm gangster like that all
these Pittsburgh there's like a million
of them right
was it a lot how many people are [ __ ]
about with high school football in
Pittsburgh I can't just put him in a
folder yeah he's bad the guy did he bags
yes I would you promised him in
Instagram shut up I did yeah Anna unlike
a newsroom story yeah cool the O'Connor
thank you so much for hooking up all my
guests with the bags every time I
appreciate it want to give you some love
cuz you [ __ ] deserve it thank you
welcome what it's done that's in there
do you think that yeah
set up real s or a national I ran out of
here to circle around what what are your
circle yeah yo it up guys uh one theme
that I'd really [ __ ] people like yo
how do I build myself awareness how do I
build my optimism how do I change my
mindset it's the people around you if
your best friend is debbie downer you're
not gonna be as optimistic as you can be
if the people that from your town that
you hang out with have no [ __ ]
ambition you're going absolutely nowhere
if you listen to your dad every day
about how the government sucks you're
not gonna love life you've got to audit
your inner circle podcast friends listen
to me listen very carefully to this
mashup and these thoughts because this
underlining tone of who you surround
yourself with absolutely fundamentally
changes who you are period and the story
when I hung out with some Silicon Valley
in 2005 to 2010 I was a different dude
when I hang out in the agency land right
now I'm a different dude when I'm like
it when I was in college at Mount Ida
different dude like you're a different
person and I'm telling you right now
this morning podcast or this podcast cuz
I know some of you listen
this podcast if I can get one of you
one person listening to this to dump one
loser person in their circle and add one
whoever is that smiley happiest [ __ ]
person at work that you don't talk to
that much that's at a cubicle around the
way or that awesome like that floor you
don't have everybody has like you have a
friend but their friend like went to
college with them you don't really know
them but like the three times you see
them a year the positive a [ __ ] and like
the [ __ ] doing things surround
yourself with those people seek out your
friends friend who brings positive vibes
and make them part of your world and cut
out your homie from college that thinks
the world sucks
watch what that addition and subtraction
does to your life Twitter one month away
from the NFL Draft actually the end of
this month how did the Dallas gonna be
in the green room when my boy Josh
Jackson first round picks baby looking
for some brands businesses that want to
biz dab in the Dallas market around the
NFL draft looking to do something gnarly
with Vader Sports get at me form below
hit me up alright let's go
[Music]